ừ ừ
à à
anh
Alo Alo
Alo ạ
anh
Alo Alo Alo ạ
anh Alo gọi bây giờ tôi bạn kia Bạn Mới
nhắc là nó ra là không hề có tiếng anh ạ
Nó xin lỗi
vì vậy Nãy giờ nói rất nhiều
à À thì
Ừ thôi tôi nói lại vậy Hôm nay là buổi
cuối bảo vệ đoán một đối ngoại thì à
ở
đây Đây là buổi cuối của bảo vệ đợt 1
thôi còn đợt 2 thì tôi chưa rõ vì đợt 2
thì về cơ bản thì cũng đang Khải tôi
liên lạc rồi khái nhóm khác ngon Vẫn còn
đang tiếp tục làm thành nha Và nếu mà
mình nhóm đấy nhiều nhóm cùng kiểu
bảo vệ tôi thì tôi sẽ sắp xếp cho một bộ
riêng trong tất cả các nhóm đấy chứ tôi
không không Cậu là livestream cảnh ngay
để hoa chấm các thứ nữa à
khi sex
chỉ còn hôm nay thì sẽ là bảo vệ những
cái nhóm mà có thể bảo vệ trong ngày hôm
nay lần cuối và và tôi sẽ livestream để
chấm qua về đồ ăn các bạn về về tài liệu
lỗi chính tả này chẳng hạn cách trình
bày tất cả cốt các bạn lin Cốt hay không
ở
ạ bây giờ trao là có bạn Hữu Bình kia
thì cũng chuẩn bị sẽ hàng vào vào thôi ạ
cô bạn kia hỏi về cái tiếng chụp tập có
cần bằng tiếng Anh nó không ra bằng
nhàng ngày còn chẳng quan trọng lắm đừng
nói đến bằng tiếng Anh đến nhà có thì
đôi khi các bạn sẽ phá sản qua được
phỏng vấn của một cái công ty nước ngoài
nhưng mà ra tôi thể không quan trọng lắm
đâu
ở nick bé Hương thì sát và mic này
Alo alo alo alo
Anh hiểu xem lại hình như là
cho tôi Tôi đang thị sát làm ít mà vẫn
bị bé
cho các bạn khác thì béo
Ừ nếu mà học muộn rồi lúc làm đồ ăn
không có nhóm thì sao chứ ra nếu bây giờ
bạn mới đăng ký nhóm đón một thì ra
không không còn nữa các bạn sẽ chủ yếu
là
Xin chào tự học về cái vụ này và bây giờ
là chuẩn bị sẵn sàng cho đoán hay mất
rồi Cái này công nhận là hơi thiệt cho
những bạn mà không không kiểu theo mình
ngay từ đầu thì sẽ khó mất theo
khi bé
đợi rồi tính sát hại
a bét
khi sex
ừ ừ
anh alo
anh alo alo alo alo ten
Bây giờ tôi nghĩ ai to hơn rồi vì tôi
đang đeo tai nghe rồi chọn tôi thì to
vãi
à à
chỉ sau hơn đội không ạ
Ô thế chắc là cái mic này đang tự nhiên
gần đây vấn đề rồi Áo kiểu
em vẫn hay vẫn tôi tôi phải mik làm mới
kiểu cắm dây vào ấy cầm dây USB vậy như
vậy vừa rút ra rút ra gặp lại thì nó to
hơn vẫn bé
Chí Minh về
Vì sao nhỉ
Ừ cái này thì à
anh alo alo alo alo alo alo
anh alo alo alo
khi sex
anh Alo ạ Alo alo
hình như là
được rồi đấy ông ạ tôi hình như đâu rồi
chọn nhầm nick của còn tay ngay khác
thôi anh đeo hai con tai nghe tai nghe
được ạ giọt mắn hơn mình buông tay nghe
ờ ờ nghe các bạn nói và có tai nghe này
có mic thằng nào nó nhận nhầm nick con
kia
khi sex
ở
bên người chưa à
Ừ ok các bạn vào Mít đi để mà vừa xem
cho tiện và cũng nghe cũng rõ hơn không
phải nghe tôi mà nghe cả các bạn khác
nữa
Hữu Bình hôm nay xung phong đầu tiên à
Hôm nay sẽ bụi bảo vệ cô ấy những nhóm
làm à những nhóm làm à Không tình nguyện
bảo vệ Hôm nay thì chắc là sẽ bảo vệ
riêng đợt với và nhóm nữa sau và
Đúng rồi tôi sẽ không nói chim gì cả Tôi
sẽ chỉ chấm riêng cậu ít cá thử thôi và
nói chung là lúc đấy phải đợi sau lâu ấy
khi nghe các bạn cứ hôm nay mà bảo vệ
được thì nên bảo vệ
Anh
hiểu Bình bắt đầu rồi
anh
[âm nhạc]
Alo Rõ rồi bạn rõ rồi à
à à
Á
và một mai nước going home nhiều vào đất
ướt ờ ờ
à à bạn Bạn nói tiếp đi Nãy giờ không có
tiếng à
Như pi đây không không khóc không tiếng
của em thì rõ rồi Anh anh vừa nãy
YouTube của anh đang nghe mất tiếng
không không sao để ạ
chào các bạn nhỏ nhất trong số này không
nhỉ Ok là cơ sở dữ liệu
ở đây để để để anh thử hỏi Ngang Qua về
cái này sửa xem nha quay quay quay lại
bên A thể trước đi
thì tại sao đây em nói à Tab với khá
nhiều thằng nhỉ
ở tại Pháp nó cắt đậu nữa Nó quản lý
thay đổi được tình trạng của Bưu
thay đổi được thông tin của tôi đất thay
đổi được thông tin của nhà sản xuất mono
nên nối với hết
những nhưng mà
nhưng mà kể mối quan hệ luôn phải có
phải ngược lại nữa cả lại em em ghi này
để mà mình hiểu mình sẽ lưu lại thông
tin đó vào trong cơ sở liệu thì cái đấy
em còn lưu âm nhỉ
tác động thì em không có lưu tới ví dụ
là các em bảo là
ăn minh đấy tác động đến cái bưu thì em
còn lưu lại là amin amin nào có tác động
đến đi phải không ta không tương tự thế
với cô Đắt hay mai phó chơi còn không
thì ông không Không thì không cần phải
thể hiện vào trong cái cho thể này của
xã hội thể này để mà từ sâu thể sẽ ra cơ
sở liệu mà khi cài đặt
đây về cơ sở dữ liệu thì
ở dưới yêu sờ và
Tab đều có hai
đều có hai cậu Token nó là để lưu và của
kỳ để lưu khi đăng nhập
thetis ở Bill em để in time in their 11
ký tự là
em ghém không nó sẽ không sẽ là đang đợi
một số là đã duyệt và ba là đại hội
Ờ
vậy Tide ở đây em không nói với tao đi
lên đây Tại em cứ để va tre em lưu nhiều
cái thai đi ở đây và cách cho nó cách
nhau bởi dấu phẩy
Ừ
ok Ờ
ở đây thật ra thì anh anh anh không biết
anh nói bạn chưa cả chút hiện về thứ
nhất à một cuộc không nên ba chị gửi như
thế là thay đi không nên
chưa chứa nhiều giá trị như thế đúng
không Bởi vì đó nó nối danh là roi các
thử thử dõi thì ra vẫn coi rồi đấy nếu
mà các bạn biết cách thì thực ra vẫn có
thể thêm mà có thể tách cái cái cái hai
ly đầy bụng cách nhau bởi dấu phẩy để
soi vào bảng thay thì vẫn làm được Nhưng
mà thường không nên ăn thế cơ à
mình nó mất đi cái răng buộc bà mất đi
Nói chung nhiều cái thấm thía Giả sử
phát trai em 50 phía sau không thể nhập
được 10 20 cái thay vì cái ID là lớn khi
đó ngoại
tiếp theo là test thì bản sát thì anh ấy
Hoa Bảo rơi thức mày bảng nữa cũng bị
kiểu tên cột nó bị lặp lại tên bảng ấy
ra mình cũng chán mày cái điều đấy
Ở đây bản bưu đi thiêu tại sao em không
có cột nào là khóa chính
Anh ở tại đó nội tới BIDV với protein
không để ai chính là đó
Đương nhiên là khoa ngoại khoa ngoại thì
nó vẫn bắt buộc cả đúng rồi nhưng mà
một bảng này vẫn lên cầu khóa chính mà à
à các
bạn có phải trí nghỉ để tránh việc làm
tại dữ liệu ấy Ví dụ là sử là cùng cái
đơn đấy anh đặt và một cái bút số lúc
xoang là thêm cái bút nữa thì không phải
là tạo thêm Blue Ivy lặp lại bi ID ở
thành phố đã hay đi không nên mà mình
chỉ cần tăng quantity lên thôi đúng
không nghe đúng rồi thì thì cách để phân
phân biệt thì mình sẽ hai cột cũng là
khóa chính
ừ ừ
ý là có BIDV và protein sẽ là khóa chính
ở đây luôn à
anh lấy thì em
ok à
A và mono fossil name kia nó có cái biểu
tượng cũng là cái khóa giống như khóa
chính kia em biết tại sao như thế nào ạ
o0o
10 cái biểu tượng đấy nhiều người sẽ bị
nhầm nó quá trình cho nó rõ không Thứ
nhất là một bảng trong một bảng mà cô tự
động tăng đấy thì cô đấy sẽ phải luôn là
khóa chính rồi và cột đầy ra thứ nhất
quá trình thôi Thế còn những cái cột
khác mà có kiểu biểu tượng kiểu có khóa
như thế Thật ra nó là em đánh nó unique
nó duy nhất ra nó sẽ hiểu nó biểu tượng
Hơi sai một tí Đúng không Nó là còn ít
đấy mẹ là kiểu nó tránh bị lặp lại chung
Ừ
Ok em không để ý luôn Ừ đúng rồi thì
thực ra em Nếu mà đã ngu nước thì ra vẫn
thể đánh con nít như cái không bây giờ
mới thấy user name kia hai ạ thay nêm
nữa nhỉ
you sẽ đem sao để remix được Tại tên
người dùng có thể
được dỡ nhà đúng rồi đúng rồi à Hết Anh
đang bị nhầm răng là và biệt danh ấy đấy
ạ có tên đăng nhập với tên là nhiều đấy
Kiểu gì thế ạ
Ừ ok ok
bật đèn xanh để môi
anh
chạy
đây là chân chính
điện thoại đây có tính năng đăng ký ở
đây có đăng ký
hiệp định sẽ đăng nhập
một sản phẩm có ấy có một con
người dùng sẽ phải chọn kích thước nó
không sẽ học thể hiện thông báo đây
được say
có những sản phẩm sẽ lặp lại tại vì nó
có coi giá tăng 2 size
có loại bye bài giảng được rồi ba kích
thước thì một cái thước nó là
màu xanh mỗi sai nó sẽ có một giá khác
nhau
AE nhập trùng máy dạ giá đây sẽ là giấy
pin tới ra mắt à
Anh
ấy
ở đây có thể thay đổi hết thông tin ở
đây đi được hết
nó không ảnh hưởng tới người khác
đoán sẽ có mua đồ hình lên cho triệu cá
mập kiệm lời cảm ơn và quay trở về trang
chủ
thông tin người dùng thì trong đây có
thay đổi không thay đổi thông tin cá
nhân ở đây
thay đổi mật khẩu
sim sách Đơn Hiền đưa hàng đã đặt trạng
thái của đó và đưa hàng đang chở đây
đây người dùng sẽ không thể không thể
hủy đơn hàng ở đây Nếu không phải lấy
hàng thì để người dùng phải liên lạc tới
thông tin cá nhân theo dưới đây tại vì
việc đặt hàng và hủy đơn hàng thì nó
đặt sĩ người bắt đầu dùng phải xem xét
kỹ trước khi muốn nhấn vào nút an toàn
Em có muốn khỏi ý thì cũng phải gọi là
gì cũng phải chú trọng tên gì đó
Về Như Ý Linh
có đăng ký nhân viên nữa đăng ký ở đây
nó sẽ là thành và nhân viên luôn
Hơi bỏ đăng ký đăng ký vào duyệt đơn rồi
Rất đơn bản thân vui bỏ bỏ vào nó bị ông
nhân viên
admin sữa được hết câu hỏi luôn đây là
dưới đây vừa rồi cho Huy được luôn vãi
ra sao
đây lên hàng vừa đặt sau có gì Thủy Tại
nó bị trùng F5 lại cái nó hết thật
nó không thể về làm đi Đang đang chờ
được Nó chỉ có gì và hỏi thôi
anh sẽ thông tin Bệnh viện anh góp
password luôn à sự thay đổi mật khẩu cho
nhân viên đã luôn
Xóa được bản thân Mà nó nhìn đây là xóa
màu hậu ở đây không Không có điện thoại
ở đây không có chiếc đèn pin là không có
super beam à ơi nhưng mà em đổi cái ID
Người xóa thành người khác được mà
Ở
đời ai đi nhân viên hành một vẫn xóa đâu
mà đúng không
anh hiểu em copy rồi cái web
chưa kiểm tra bác Hai nó
tất cả là không nên hiển thị ra password
người dùng không không nên nó cái nó nó
là nhân viên đấy chứ phải là ừ đúng rồi
nhưng mà liệu nhưng mà thực tế nhiều
người sẽ dùng một cái bắt có cho mọi tài
khoản của họ thì chị mà họ đổi mật khẩu
thành cái hiểu cái gì đó nickname họ gì
đó thì em hoàn toàn thể biết được họ có
thói quen đặt mật khẩu như nào để có thể
vào tài khoản của người khác được đúng
không Thế này là cũng tránh để được đấy
em hiểu đây Thực ra đây ảnh nói qua luôn
à Thật là nếu thế sẽ có người bảo là
thêm bia ra sự là nhân viên em bảo quên
mật khẩu thì làm như nào thì đương nhiên
là em vẫn hỗ trợ việc là nhất là cài mật
khẩu cho họ
thế nên là khi mẹ bấm mò sửa lìa Thì em
bấm em thứ bóng mờ sợi thì ạ số tự động
điền lại mật khẩu
anh như thế này bởi vì hoàn toàn áo khi
mà điện tự động Điền mật khẩu như này
thì mình hoàn toàn thể đổi thì đến phút
này thành password hành tách thì nó sẽ
nhìn lại được mật khẩu đúng không ạ thì
lại thì thế nên là thế thế nên là không
không khí tự động nhạc cụ để chống Đúng
rồi Nhưng mà có thấy bạn kia đã nói là
sẽ mã hóa Mật khẩu này
thì sẽ luôn là mật khẩu mới này hoặc
giống như hồi trước tôi làm ở công ty cũ
Thì sẽ là có cái nút để mà reset mật
khẩu về mặc định là 123 hành án hoa cà
thậm chí là reset mật khẩu thành một cái
5 ký tự bất kỳ Xong rồi gửi mail của của
nhân viên đúng không để chỉnh nhân viên
mới biết cũng được em Em hiểu ý anh
không thì để một cái cái gì đó
ở nhà mà thôi đón một thì không cần phải
cháu suốt thì nghỉ anh thế chứ bây sản
phẩm hơn thật nữa đây nó còn nó có khách
say thì nó khác sai khác giá thì nó sẽ
lòi ra hai cái sản phẩm hai dòng ở đây
đây đây những chi tiết đó sẽ ra vận
chuyển để về trang đây
đi sản phẩm đây
để lúc thêm giá cái thứ ở đây nó sẽ lấy
cho hết em lên
nên chắc nó sẽ thôi mà
người quản lý hóa đơn phải quay lại một
tí em Em cố định luôn là bốn cơ à
2000 bấm bấm chết tới luôn tới được luôn
nhưng mà nhưng mà
thêm thể sau đó anh sẽ điền 2 trong đống
này thì nó bị lỗi gì không
ở nhà không
Ok tra kiểm tra mạng rồi đúng không
cài đặt
anh
được Anh thấy ở Khánh chi tiết các từ
cái hướng rồi có chí tự các chi tiết đơn
hàng đấy thông tin hết tất cả
ta sẽ ra một tab riêng tab mới để cho
tiện cho Việt chất Đơn
Vì sao kok cũng cũng tấm đi
còn cái gì nữa
à à
à Dạ hết rồi thống kê cửa này Thống kê
thưa các bạn làm thống kê chị cũng kiểu
màu mè thôi chứ như mình nói gì cũng
không Không vẫn chưa đủ thực tế người
dùng vẫn thực sự là chưa nhìn vào đấy để
mà đánh giá được mà trong web tăng tốt
hay xấu lên gì đó ngon nên theo cả thời
gian cho rồi Nhiều cái nữa rất nhiều nữa
chứ
ờ ờ
Ừ Ok
bây giờ thường mở cốt lên đi
dễ thương mà có nền anh thương
em Em thử chỉ anh cái đoạn mà em làm cái
thống kê vừa rồi của Việt Nam mình không
vậy admin
tại đoạn nào
ở
Đà Nẵng Yến
anh cứ này thế này cái câu Apple ở dưới
rồi kìa là em đang làm gì đấy này em
tự em chết coi coi nó có hay không Nếu
nếu nó còn không thì nếu nó không có
điện không có đơn hàng trong từ thời
gian đó thì em sẽ đặt cho nó không cho
doanh thu của tuần nó bằng không đặt ở
chỗ này sẽ để kiểm tra coi coi có tuần
đó nó có đơn hàng không trong thời gian
trong một tuần nó có đơn hàng không từ
ngày hôm nay tới 7 ngày trước
chồng ở thời gian đó nếu nó Ừ nếu tồn
tại thì lấy
Ừ tôi đè Còn không thì cho nó bạn không
Ok học gì đấy rồi Thôi cảm ơn cảm ơn em
nhé Còn còn muốn trình bày thì não
Ý anh muốn hỏi gì không
em không trả thế rồi Ok
vậy sao
a nhong nhóm tiếp sao nhà có nhóm nào
buồn à Hôm nay bảo vệ nốt mà
à à
thật lòng em vừa rồi ở nhóm mấy nhỉ
hỗ trợ giống người ta lắm Ok để anh trả
nữa
à à
Ừ
tớ không không còn nhỏ mà xuống phòng
thế tôi cứ kéo Cốt về để mà chấm trước
nhé
em chưa file Powerpoint Thế giờ hết
Ừ nếu mày chuẩn bị đi
anh tâm sự tuổi hồng À ừ thì bây giờ các
bạn cứ Các bạn cứ nhắn các câu hỏi thắc
mắc vì hai chủ đề gì đó thì tôi sẽ chấm
Thực ra tôi chỉ chấm qua khá nhanh thôi
Bởi khi mới có một vài nhóm lên mặt thì
sau đó thì mình mình sẽ ngồi tâm sự và
trả lời một lúc không ạ
à Còn buổi hôm sau ở bắt đầu học rồi
chết rồi chứ không phải à mày ông ấy bắt
đầu giống như thời tôi còn đi học đại
học rất thích thầy tâm sự chẳng phải học
hành gì cả Thế bây giờ
à à
a a
Project area ở
Tik Tok tôi hỏi từng nhóm lấy Linh vậy
bởi vì à
Cho tôi tải cô HPV ở máy bên kia
xe máy laptop của tôi mà laptop cho tôi
đang không
phụ nữ như thế có khi bây giờ có tâm sự
đi rồi tôi sẽ chấm Sau Vậy xin phép dùm
sau nhé
khi chúng tôi ở Tải cốt từ Long về xong
rồi lấy link ít nữa thì sao thì đầu tiên
là bây giờ mày ông Cư thắc mắc gì người
ông thắc mắc gì thì cứ
em cứ nói thôi ông ạ
Ừ tao mắc đôi khi không cần lấy về công
nghệ tin trong Bởi vì tôi hướng đến là
phía sau 500m
bàn về nhiều cái tình cảm chẳng ăn ạ
chú ý trời rồi tâm sự thôi
thế hả Có làm cốt dạng này anh cho vợ
thêm lời khuyên tự ý em là làm xong mới
bán hàng ở nhà hay như nào
Em làm thế nào để có người yêu thì anh
có này à Ở
ý nghĩa tôi tự trả lời rồi nhưng mà thôi
Thì bởi vì
Em có coi như nhiều bạn hôm nay tôi tin
vào như bão ngày mới á Tôi sẽ nhắc lại
Anh bảo là
nếu không phải quan điểm là mấy ông
Ừ ông phải xác định đối tượng đã đúng ạ
Ông không phải nó cái vu vơ được ông vậy
lên một cái kéo hàng gõ làm Xác định đối
tượng đó Cứ sợ là ông là một người dân
trí thức dân công nghệ thông tin chỉ
được kiểu màu sách không phải là kiểu
máy anh nha Lại rapper hot boy à
ở chỗ kiểu dáng pasport các thứ thứ thì
mấy ông sẽ phải tiếp cận đối tượng của
ông sẽ ở những nơi như nào đó ngoại
không không phải là ở quán net Không
phải đâu thường còn ăn có lãi nhiều ạ
thưởng với bạn đi cùng nhiều người ông ạ
Không phải là kiểu ông cứ ở nhà rồi đợi
có ai đó kiểu đến mở cửa đến Gõ Cửa xong
rồi thử giày giống như
là mày tiết thời tiết thì cũng phải bước
ra ngoài ngày hôm đấy mình có người biết
đến đúng ạ Vậy thì chứng tỏ mấy ông sẽ
phải như nào và đương nhiên là Thực ra
bây giờ là tiện hơn Do thời đấy là mình
còn có mạng nữa anh ra là tôi thấy à gặp
một người ngoài đời để mà nói chuyện với
người đấy xin số người đấy rồi hỏi
Facebook về đấy đừng phát bãi bảo có
người yêu rồi thì nó xấu hổ lắm thế này
là tốt nhất là mấy ông hãy tiếp cận qua
mạng biết trước qua sở thích đã biết
được đoán anh nhiều chưa Tôi không thích
mày cái bạn kiểu đi ẩn nhiêu rồi khó
chịu đấy
ờ ờ là vẫn còn thử ngày đang status Thái
Bình nhé cho dù có nhiêu đây thì
khi người ông sẽ tìm những người cùng
chung sở thích ví dụ là mấy ông đặc biệt
làm những cái sở thích mà ông nghĩ là
kiểu
nó cả tính của ông ấy thì ông sẽ tìm
những cái người cùng chung sở thích cậu
thích những cái bếp Đấy Bình luận trong
đấy vẫn một cách mà tôi đã từng nghĩ tìm
tôi bạn nói tôi từng làm cái tool để mà
cho
kiểu cào ấy Grow Cao ấy nữa lấy dữ liệu
cổ phiếu về ở
hơn ba mình bạn nữ ở Hà Nội cũng search
Cũng sở hữu đầy rồi cảm thấy tôi tôi
dùng tool để tôi lọc tay từng bạn một
thế là tôi không phiên với ông như thế
sao nó không nhưng mà nhưng mà nếu không
hiểu ý tôi mà đúng không Ờ
Ê bà Ok trà sữa bạn xác định được đối
tượng rồi Tiếp theo là mà để mà
gì mình tồn tại không mắt bạn đấy thì
cái đơn giản thì đó là à
Ừ
anh đơn giản đó là mấy ông phải kiểu
tương tác với bạn đấy không phải là cầu
bạn đấy vừa mới chấp nhận kết bạn gái
lập tức cấu nhắn tin em sau này muốn nó
tên con mình là gì
A
gọi như thế đó sẽ nhà ở sẽ kiểu à
chị sẽ kiểu dạng là
hãy để thoải mái tự nhiên điều
khi có dịp nào đó bạn ấy đang cái gì có
thể bình luận được thì vào bình luận hãy
không mày bình luận vô duyên ấy nhé
Đừng cố tỏ ra mình hài hước nghe có lấy
vợ chưa mình sẽ bên anh một thằng vô
duyên Tôi chuẩn bị rồi mạn tôi biết mà
Đấy thì à
A và kiểu sau sau vài lần cho Tấn tác
như thế thì mày Ông ấy nên nhắn tin hoặc
Gà bây giờ mấy bạn nữ đấy thật ra là có
nhã ý mà Mấy bạn hãy trở còn ngại ý gì
đó đôi khi bạn đang Sony
ví dụ sau đi theo dạng được mấy ông thể
vào để hỏi thì càng tốt nhưng mà đôi khi
A1 khi các bạn đấy Chơi cờ thế các bạn
sẽ bắt lưỡi bắt cá thả lưới nên thành ra
là ông sẽ là một trong số thôi nhưng anh
người thôi không biết được
à nhưng mà nói chung là tôi vẫn có niềm
tin đó là nếu mà thực sự hai người hợp
nhau thì nó dễ ổn thôi
à mà ông không cần phải lo quá
Ừ cái đấy tôi vừa nói cái mình cái cơ
bản qua kiểu tôi đúc kết được còn nếu mà
Mấy ông hỏi cụ thể hơn thì tôi sẽ trả
lời của thể hơn
a tiếp theo tôi Bây giờ nhiều bạn có vẻ
đang bình luận hơn rồi Nếu tôi xin phép
trả lời câu từ ở trên nhé à
ờ ờ đầu tiên thì có bạn bảo là kinh
nghiệm để mà khi đi làm à
A và kiểu con ạ đi Lương Đức là kiểu
thỏa thuận về lương thi
thí nghiệm cái khi đi làm cái này cũng
mẹ công ty này đó là tôi cảm thấy nó khá
thoải mái như kiểu là
thứ nhất là họ cần mình nếu mà giờ sử ở
mình cũng là đội tốt rồi nên không cần
phải cẩu căng thẳng có bó quá
Ừ ông đã có thể nhìn đời bằng con mắt
kiểu khinh người rồi
được ngồi ăn tận ở đấy đúng không
bà
Bà Chính vì như thế nên là thỏa thuận
lương nó khá phải máy của cả hai bên Nói
chung là chấp nhận thì làm không thì
thôi để đổi mấy bạn kiểu có hơn 10 năm
kinh nghiệm đội lên sẽ hiểu như thế sẽ
hơi chảnh một tí cái thế
còn mới đi thực tập Thì mày chả có quyền
đó Hỏi gì Cái gì cả ngoại bởi vì mấy ông
còn phải ạ học phải
Em học xong rồi phải ở phải chủ yếu lấy
kiến thức lấy kinh nghiệm nên nên là
người ông phải tìm công ty nào mà cho
những cái điều đấy Và không nên để quá
lâu khi mà học xong hết toàn bộ những
cái thứ thể học rồi nó lỡ cả công ty
công ty đấy Kiểu trả lương vẫn còn bèo
bọt quá thì giống như tôi nhỉ Thôi
khi sex
ờ ờ
các
bạn Kiều bảo làm trang web bán tài khoản
Anh không biết nói cái thể loại đấy nên
nó không biết trả lời như thế nào
Ừ nhưng mà nếu mà bán tài khoản thì kiểu
là xe bắt code hay trai kia gì đó thì ạ
cái đấy khá đau đầu đấy phải cái vụ để
qua mạng quyển xe kỹ cũng gì đó
anh em cơ bản ra rồi muốn chuyển qua pp
như thế nào thì hôm trước mình có nói
quá hả Bộ là thật ra nếu mà các bạn có
thể tặng ra rồi các ba bạn các bạn học
xanh pm dễ hơn nó dễ hơn và đặc biệt là
mình buổi sau mình sẽ dạy về mới xe opec
các bạn sẽ thấy hoạch cái này Java nó
phức tạp hơn và mệnh do là các bạn học
ra vào nên các bạn dễ hiểu hơn rất nhiều
nên là mình cảm thấy à các bạn từ Java
song với P là cứ như nó sẽ bị nó nhẹ
nhõm hơn khi mà học và cũng sẽ hiểu hơn
đấy bởi vì khi mà Mấy ông thấy nhẹ nhõm
rồi mấy ông học có gì ở hứng hứng thú
hơn
khi dùng suy giáp có được web không có
một sự thật là tôi thấy ở bây giờ ngôn
ngữ lập trình nào cũng hình như nó hỗ
trợ cốt được xanh web rồi phải trên cái
thư viện gì đó Cái đấy Tôi không rõ lắm
ờ ờ hướng dẫn tạo cái ly cân xin việc
anh đi theo cá thì à mình đã từng hướng
dẫn các bạn làm cái CP rồi thì đi cần
nộp tương tự thế nhưng mà Ly cần thì nó
bây giờ nó vô mạng xã hội thì sẽ là tôi
nghĩa là sẽ đăng mấy cái nó cũng
thể hiện mình là con người điều gì đó và
cũng nhờ mày không phải kết nối chủ động
kết nối nhiều HR trên đầy bể Đông Hán ở
kinh koong anh bình luận các tiểu sử của
người ta thôi
à à
ở chỗ ngồi và bạn kia có nói kiểu có
luôn tài khoản ghi hấp để mà kiểu đề mà
đưa dẫn chừng luôn
Ừ tự nhiên ông bắt nhờ nhỉ Cái giây lười
làm
Ừ cái này thôi các bạn tôi đã nói đồ án
thì nó sẽ khá thực tế nên là mấy ông
cũng phải quen dần cái thực tế đấy Đó là
có thể đồng phát Cái người mà đang làm
khá nhiều cốt luôn mà bạn ấy nhỉ thì
không phải là ông sẽ không bơ được một
cô đấy Có khi ông muốn phải nhảy vào để
sửa cô đấy con Vân thì ta cái đấy nó
không giúp ông Tăng lương lên đâu ông nó
là bổn phận của ông rồi nơi ông phải
quen với việc nói chung nhà mình sẽ gặp
rất nhiều thể loại người người ta có thể
ở lại còn làm cản ông nói ra thể đang cố
tốt rồi người ta vì do gì đấy nhỉ và Vân
Và thậm chí về sau chỉ nhậu mà sẽ người
như thế thế nên là không trách được ai
đây cả mình mình kéo mình cứ suy nghĩ à
nhà mình có suy nghĩ đơn giản nội tôi
tôi không nên nhiều người nào nhưng mà
ngay Chiều nay này Sếp của tôi gọi cho
tôi vẫn bún qua điện thoại để mất liên
tục nhưng mà tội làm Buồn ngủ vãi tôi
tôi sẽ không không khó chịu với công
việc này tôi sẽ không kéo cáo Tại sao mẹ
dọn này giờ vẫn không Tôi chỉ đơn giản
là tôi sẽ lấy nghĩa vụ mình kiểu
sếp cũng đang bận rộn làm cái thứ Hữu
đúng không Mình cũng làm nửa đêm qua tôi
có ngồi sửa cốt các thứ mà đấy thì tôi
khá thoải mái suy nghĩ khá thoáng về một
cái vấn đề đấy tôi nghĩa mấy ông nên thế
anh không tôi sẽ không chia sẻ tôn cái
tool mà tôi
làm cái đoạn là các bạn nữ kia đâu Thực
ra cái đấy cái tool này dễ công chỉ cần
thì nhớ ông dễ làm thì mà bây hội đưa
nha bây giờ Facebook nó chặt hơn rồi mấy
cái vụ lấy thông tin như thế nhưng mà nó
cũng sẽ làm ngồi mì hôm qua cái Trang
viết hát của tôi xem cốt lết hấp tôi
thường hay Cốt về tool Facebook mấy ông
có thể hiểu qua nó cả là cái tool này
hoàn toàn không phải mỗi con gái nha cả
chạy được chuyển đổi từ Male female rồi
xong
ở Bạch Tuyết ở có người đến tận nhà bán
táo đưa được à ơi nhờ tôi nhớ Nhầm
cái gì tinh rồi nghỉ à
ai giày thủy tinh là hoàn Bạch Tuyết nó
là gì nhỉ à
Ừ nó là thứ tự nhiên tôi quên à Dạo này
em Đúng rồi Bọn em ơi Nhưng mà Bạch
Tuyết thì về cơ bản thì cô ấy cũng ở
trong nhà
gặp hoàng tử đâu Cô ấy cũng phải làm
thanh thiên bạch nhật ở ngoài đường thì
hoàng tử mới thấy mà đúng ạ Mấy ông tự
tin là ngoại hình ông đủ để khiến cho
người khác nhìn vào về muốn hôn luôn
luôn Không không đúng không
mà Mấy ông xã sang nằm đấy cho thằng một
người bất kỳ hôn à
à à
Nhà em có máy ảnh anh chị em tán gái
bằng máy ảnh Được không Ờ tôi thấy bây
giờ khá nhiều Thọ hẹn hò được với các
bạn mẫu giữa tôi không khuyến khích lệ
việc làm mấy ông chọn một ngày nào đó
chỉ đi thẳng gái
Nhưng mà
thực sự thì
mày ông tôi tôi nói đấy mấy ông mà coi
cái nghề của ông thú vị thì và làm các
bạn khác và miền nhàng chứ nhiếp ảnh đã
khiến các bạn khác thú vị Bởi vì các bạn
đấy Con gái về cơ bản thì họ ở họ sẽ
giải thích những người nào làm họ bất
ngờ mà ông lại bất ngờ trình ảnh Bạn ơi
đang từ nhà ấy thành như nào đây bạn
cũng bất ngờ bạn thích đấy bạn sẽ trầm
trồ ngang nhiên với vân phong cách mà
cho Annabelle sở thích của bạn đây Tìm
bạn sẽ thích có cái ảnh các thứ nghệ
thuật ở được mà
ô
ồ bạn kia bảo lạ là bạn đấy 1 năm kinh
nghiệm đi làm
470 đô một tháng bây giờ sau 6 tháng thì
đi được đi lại lương thì lời khuyên của
mình là nếu mà bạn chỉ theo phen À thì
ra là
bạn cần em phải nâng cao trình độ hơn
nữa thì các bạn thì các bạn mới điều
lương nó dễ bác em thì đôi khi nó không
cần đưa lưng lắm thì thường sẽ được tăng
theo doanh số công ty rồi chỉ kìa đến
ngưỡng cái ngưỡng là khá cao rồi mới khó
đi Lương hơn thôi nhờ còn fan thì mình
thấy à Bạn phải cải thiện lên kỹ năng có
thể kỹ năng về đồ họa khi năng về làm ra
Suite cấp thứ thứ thì mấy hệ lương hơn
được chứ không thì ở người ta sẽ nghĩ ạ
Bạn sẽ làm sao diện các bạn từ trước nay
vẫn thế khó một điều lương Tôi nghĩ tôi
nghĩ hầu ho gà không thì tăng khá ít
Ừ Từ ngày anh giới thiệu mà tung
Facebook này nào em cũng bị checkpoint
anh cũng bị chơi coi hàng ngày mà Thì
hãy quen dần và cái ai rồi Thế thì khó
khăn nick thôi về trước tôi đọc câu này
ở đâu đấy nhưng mà
cũng chỉ nghe vì thế nên là tôi nửa thấy
à Mạng xã hội khá quan trọng nên nửa Tôi
nghĩ là tôi vẫn không muốn phụ thuộc
hoàn toàn vào nó Tôi không muốn kéo dạng
giống như là hồi giống như tôi từng nói
từng Suýt mất Facebook không biết được à
Nếu mà tôi mất như thế Tôi sẽ như nào và
và kiểu mình bị ảnh hưởng bởi vì rõ ràng
là chuẩn ra là nó là phục vụ mình nhưng
mình lại cảm thấy rất là vấn đề gì đó
Khi mà nó có vấn đề đúng ạ Nó là phục vụ
mình thì rõ ràng là là
khi làm mình phải luôn thoải mái vì nó
chứ không phải Ngược lại nếu hiểu cho
ngọn
cũng gần giống như là ở người ta bảo là
cái cảm giác mà
ông cái cảm giác thấp khó tin thì mà ông
cảm thấy có Xe tải lao vào người ông ấy
cũng tương đương với cái cảm giác thót
tim khi mà ông nằm thôi cái điện thoại
thì gỡ ra nhà có gì đó là bây giờ cậu tự
nhiên rơi điện thoại đây không nói gì mà
nó Đắt hay rẻ nhá
mà nói về việc kiểu là do là kiểu mình
đã bị à tâm tâm lý kiểu là kiểu mình bị
phụ thuộc vào nó ít rồi thế
cho nó hiểu lý do ngoãn thì Đấy mình
mình mà như tôi từng nói mình mà vừa qua
là những cách bài toán tâm lý học mà
nhiều người bị dính như thế mình sẽ hơn
rất nhiều người có tiền chứ
à à
ờ ờ
sau khi xài yaourt thì mình thể dùng
Apple dạng lớn
à à dùng Apple tạo một file
rất lớn vào Apple
Vì mình chưa hiểu ý câu của bạn lắm bạn
lại đi xuất file vào hay là Insert dữ
liệu khá lớn là hay như nào nhỉ
khi sex
354 mới đi học tập quá muộn không ở
tôi quen mấy người còn 35 tuổi bắt đầu
học lập trình cơ mà chẳng có gì muộn ở
đây cả thoải mái thôi
Ừ nếu đồng nữa không quan trọng thì anh
muốn làm nghề gì
ông ấy chứng tỏ ấy mới ông chưa chưa
hiểu tôi
em có một sự thờ ơ chuyện ngành này
không phải tiền lương
cho tôi à ơi
à Tôi đang dạy mấy ông và nam miễn phí
nữa mà phải chọn là
tôi chọn khá nhiều thứ không cô luôn
nghĩ về đồng tiền sau cùng
mọi người đam mê đam mê Cái ngành công
nghệ tin này bởi vì nó ngoài được là nó
kiểu mình mình học được ngoài việc nó
học mình học được tôi học được khá nhiều
thứ nhé nhưng mà nhưng mà Bởi vì nó còn
giúp ích cho bản thân mình bởi vì tôi là
một người ấy cũng như giúp ích gì cho
người khác cũng như nó đang xu thế mà
vẫn được thì ở lần sau nhá
Ừ nhưng mà ví dụ
còn dạy học cũng thế cũng để truyền cảm
hứng nó sẽ hơn nữa
khi phát cả mà gì hả Tôi nói tôi giàu để
mà
để mà đi đâu chia sẻ các thư không nó sẽ
phát người khác tôi sẽ không phát theo
dõi giống composers deforka tôi thấy nó
hơi bị sao ý mà tất cả có mời ông tham
lam có tài khoản đống tiền mà vẫn còn đi
sang sang thẻ rồi khác không thích chơi
ấy thế tôi sẽ chia sẻ những cái gì ở ví
dụ như chia sẻ những khóa học về nhắn từ
ai cũng thể
hình ảnh để xem ai có nhu cầu thì xem
trở lại
khi sex
ừ ừ
anh em hết nghĩa mật khẩu mới á giống
như anh làm thì anh cứ đánh số mật khẩu
Thôi bây giờ mật khẩu của anh là bà số
cuối là 49 thức cám chị anh ăn đổi 49
lần mật khẩu mới
hãy làm như thế nó sẽ vui chung nữa
Ừ ok Bây giờ có vẻ các bạn đang chưa hỏi
thêm gì thì mình xin phép tâm sự với cái
mà
mấy hôm nay mình có nghĩ
ừ ừ
có ông nói chung nhà sau hơn nửa năm tôi
ở trong nhà suốt thì gần đây tôi được
khá nhiều người gạt đi cà phê bởi vì à
họ biết được vào tôi mới chưa đây thì họ
họ ban đầu kiểu rủ đi ăn ủi với vân cũng
như là ở
động viên hoặc cả lâu lâu lắm rồi anh em
ấy thăm nhau đấy
Ừ thì à
à
Tôi nghĩ là kéo
chuyện tình cảm thì thì
khi tôi cảm thấy rồi tôi
luôn luôn hướng đến một cái tình yêu
kiểu dạng là tốt đẹp cho cho bạn thân
nghĩa là khiến cho bạn thân thốt lên
khiến cho cả hai tốt lên nên khi mà mối
quan hệ nó cảm thấy là xấu cho gà hay
tối mới bắt đầu dừng lại chứ thủ đoạn
Không có gì to tát cả nghe tội không hẳn
là buồn kiểu kiểu bị ảnh hưởng với nó
buồn vì nó lắm Tuy nhiên là về xã hội về
sau thì cũng sẽ buồn khi mà nhớ đến cảnh
Nhạn biết đâu Tự nhiên nhớ đến cũng thể
buồn gì đó thì tôi sẽ không tiếc thời cả
từ ngày kết thúc trong Email của mọi thứ
mà
A và thức à Tôi cũng là một người hay đi
nghĩ các trường hợp trước rồi không biết
mấy ông như thế không Hay ở đâu Tôi học
lập trình về tôi càng như thế hơn ở tính
hết các trường hợp kể cả trường hợp và
xấu nhất và tệ nhất rồi nên thành ra cái
gì bây giờ xảy ra tội không hẳn là bất
ngờ đã mọi thứ cậu nó có thể vốn nó sẽ
đi theo cái lỗi trình đấy nên thành ra
mới không bất ngờ không kiểu dạng này
sóc sóc gì cả lại bình thưởng
à à
anh Dũng lại Lập trình là ông nào đó
đúng không Không biết nhưng nhờ ông từng
vào đây bình luận 0
Ừ đúng rồi tuần sau sẽ bắt đầu học à Ok
Đấy
là sao học ok mới sẽ từ từ
ừ ừ cho các nhiều bạn sẽ bất ngờ đặc
biệt ở tôi đang bài hôm trước đăng bài
thông báo chia tay nhưng mà những người
cứ tưởng thông báo cười
rồi Phải chúng mình
thì gai nó không hẳn cái gì đó to tát mà
Thế nên tôi không hẳn là muốn muốn kể ra
muốn khoe ở đây như má Thôi thì bởi vì
các bạn cũng biết được à tôi mấy lần tôi
sắp cơm cho mấy ông nội nên là đợt này
cũng chia sẻ cho mấy ông mấy ông đã cảm
thấy đỡ tủi thân à
đề thi thì thì đó tiến hệ cũng nói đó là
bởi vì là tôi quan điểm mà tình yêu nó
sẽ là một thứ sẽ khiến cho cuộc sống này
trở nên có thêm màu sắc nó không phải
cuộc sống này biến thành màu hồng Nó sẽ
chị cuộc sống này thêm một rất nhiều màu
sắc và rất nhiều thăng trầm các thử thứ
nên thành ra là tôi thấy tình yêu là một
thứ khá quan trọng trong cuộc sống và
kiểu gì tôi cũng có thể tôi sẽ lại đi
tìm
một nửa kia hoàn hảo của mình với thường
anh nghĩ thế cho đến khi không như cảm
thấy không thể tìm nữa thôi à à
Ừ nhưng mà thực ra là
nói thế thôi nhưng mà cũng phải nói lại
đó là mấy ông cũng đừng nên kiểu dạng là
tôi từng nói đừng nói theo phong trào
rồi tất cả mọi người cùng hẹn hò cùng
yêu đương thì mình cũng phải lên Thế
mình mình có phải nên yêu bản thân là ăn
mình phải hiểu bản thân muốn gì và Vân
Đã đôi khi là nhiều người về sau mới
nhận ra mình sống một mình còn ổn hơn có
trong một quan hệ thì vì mình còn chưa
hiểu rõ bản thân mình cũng như là chẳng
ai có thể đáp ứng được điều đấy Nói
chung nhà mấy ông chỉ nên tìm mối quan
hệ khi mà ông sống đủ tốt rồi mà
Ừ ông cảm thấy là là
áo kiểu dạng là cuộc sống mình đợi chị
thiếu mỗi cái đấy
Ừ chứ không phải là nhiều người thiếu
rất nhiều cái và quyết định chọn vì một
mối quan hệ để mà giải quyết tất cả
những cái kia vị ví dụ của tôi nha và là
kiểu ông ông sống tận hưởng của bạn bè
đi chơi có sự cho vui vẻ rồi thì ông
hiểu rằng ông nghĩ về chuyện tình cảm
cũng được nhưng mà khi mà ông tránh có
cái gì cả
ông đang chán là rất nhiều thứ đúng là
ông cũng thể tìm mình tình yêu để mà là
một cái gì ở động lực cũng đúng Nhưng mà
Ừ cái ngưỡng cây cái cây cái trách nhiệm
cái tình yêu Đấy nó sẽ gánh vác nhiều
quá nó là động lực duy nhất của ông và
thứ duy nhất ông có thành ra là kiểu nó
sẽ ông sẽ bị ảnh hưởng rất nhiều bởi nó
cũng như là nó mà có vấn đề gì đó cũng
sẽ bị tiêu cực rất nhiều Tôi từng bị thế
mà tôi từng thế này là Hãy nghe tôi
khuyên thật mấy ông này đã ông sẽ không
cần nhanh trường hợp rủi ro nữa chừng
nào tốt thì như nó sẽ Nó là một cái thứ
gì đó vực vực công dậy nhưng mà nó lầm
thứ có thể gì mong xuống bởi vì lúc Nếu
không có gì trong tay cả em hãy ra khi
uống mất là ông cảm thấy ông mất toàn bộ
mọi thứ ông hiểu gì đâu không
Ừ thì thì đấy là một tình yêu thật à
Không hẳn nặng
Ừ
nó gọi tình yêu tôi xích tình yêu đọc
lại nó có thể ảnh hưởng rất lớn đến ông
ấy nên là
mình nên cân nhắc mấy ông Kiều dạng là
khi mà không có bạn bè chơi thì không
phải là mấy ông đi tìm người yêu đến
chơi cũng cá thứ mấy ông mấy ông phải
cậu phải tìm được bạn bè hay tìm Mọi thứ
trước đã
cho xe Tôi đang hơi dạy đời thì nhưng mà
tô ý nghĩa là nhiều ông vẫn chưa trải
đời chưa trẻ nhiều hồn tôi về chuyện
tình cảm nên chả tôi nói được
Ừ đúng rồi xong khỏe rodgers xin đi làm
được luôn Tôi đang có hướng để mà cho
các bạn sau hòa sau là chắc chắn mình
không phải đi làm được lưng 78 triệu
ngon lành luôn các thứ
bây giờ là nun hay ăn ý file hay không
vậy anh ừ
Anh Nô là chị luôn là chưa từng có hoặc
cũng giống nghẹn efile theo pass wif còn
không làm chị nó bị mất rồi nhưng mà tôi
thế Bây giờ tôi cũng đang nói dùng từ
nhỏ tôi vẫn đang à Thử tìm hiểu
cho tôi vẫn thử đang thử kiểu
Anh vẫn đang có hi vọng Thì đó nên là
tôi nghĩ là không phải mỗi không Tôi
đang nghén nhóm nên con số ảo rõ hơn à
Ừ đúng rồi bạn kia nói yêu khi sẵn sàng
cho mày yêu khi cô đơn cũng đúng Mọi
việc cô đơn không phải mỗi Cô đơn nữa vì
có thể mình mình dành thời gian cho bản
thân mình thì đúng là mình một mình thì
có thể dùng thử có đỡ được nhưng mà
nghĩa làm chị mình cần nên có bạn bè nữa
Chứ không kiểu tất cả chỉ biết mỗi mỗi
người yêu thôi là nó hơi bị tiêu cực quá
ở
người lớn người lớn thì mày yêu ấy Đổi
tô quan điểm cái tinh cho trẻ con tình
yêu người lớn tình yêu trẻ con đấy đôi
khi bám nhau và ngay tình yêu người lớn
sẽ kiểu vẫn vẫn vẫn nhớ về nhau nhưng mà
sẽ hiểu vì nhau kiểu làm động lực hơn
nhiều cái để tình yêu thì nó tốt hơn
mà không cần nói lúc nào cũng phải cậu
gắn chặt nhau
anh em không có bạn bè khác giới thì có
được cho bình thường không
có sợ đâu Em thật là bây giờ em mà sống
một mình cũng chẳng ai ý kiến thì em ra
em không bạn bè Xuka người khác có thể
hơi bất ngờ rằng ai ý kiến gì em sống
như nào cả mình không cần lại nhìn vào
người khác để mình sống mà nó cực thoải
mái thôi nhưng mà nhưng mà tí anh à đấy
việc em không muốn kết bạn Còn khi mà em
muốn kết bạn mà em không kết bạn được
thì thì thì em phải học cách đúng ạ
Ừ nếu quay lại thì sao anh quay lại kiểu
Giả sử chia tay quay lại khi chia tay
quay lại thì
Ồ thông báo điểm luôn đơn giản đó là
cái lý do chia tay nó phải nó phải mất
rồi thì mình mới quay lại còn không thì
thôi
Anh muốn được yêu thì phải chấp nhận bị
ghét đúng không
ở
phía chữa rồi nghĩ cái đấy nhưng mà ờ ờ
ờ ờ muốn phải là muốn tỏ tình thì sẽ có
thành công và thất bại một người ông
phải tình những trường hợp như thế thôi
tôi nghĩ
chắc ý bạn đấy như thế mà không hiểu ý
bạn cái chấp nhận bị ghét là cái gì
cô
bạn thân khác giới Ờ tự nhiên tôi nhờ
câu của pin quá lại sẽ mở cái không
a few pew
bản thân giới
Ừ
thì mất tiền bị sao nhỉ Sao nha
Đợi chị ạ
Em nói đi ừ
ừ ừ
Ừ Vậy tí nhá
khi
con gái tôi chẳng hiểu được nghĩa là bạn
thân thôi tôi lại
cho tôi bảo nó không Câu này đơn giản
như này thôi này
em không có đàn ông và đàn bà không nói
cấp 2 nhé cấp 2 nhỏ hơn từ cấp 2 đổi
xuống nhỏ hơn không nói nha chỉ từ cấp
ba đội lên con trai con đã đến với nhau
ấy không có cái gì chỉ là nói chuyện cho
vui Ok mộ tệ là người dưng nước lã người
làm chung bạn bè à hay là người yêu
trước mắt một là phật hay là không không
có kiểu bạn thân là bạn thân con gái tôi
chẳng hiểu được nghĩa là bạn thân con
gái bạn thân là chia sẻ được người yêu
chia sẻ được thôi đúng không Rồi thì là
kêu là có thể đi chơi với Chung nói với
nhau Ủa thế bạn bè bình thường đi chơi
chung với nhau tại cho đến lẻ
đi chơi chung với nhau mình phải ga lăng
trả tiền mình hỏi là thích xem phim gì
mình phải chia sẻ với nó mình được nó
cái gì thì mình có lỗi bạn thân kiểu gì
mà không các bạn thân một là đến với
nhau hay là nết Bố có thế bạn thân khác
không có nhiều bạn thân được không mất
thời gian này không
anh Tiêu ơi em thích một người 35 bây
giờ người ta có gấu rồi em phải làm sao
ngơ quá vậy lúc tám có 18 đứa khác nó có
gấu đây có dấu luôn chứ chả hiện với nó
Mày có thấy tao xấu Chẳng qua tao yêu
mày tao mới tỏ tình với mày Tao nói thật
lòng với mày là tao muốn đến với mày
thôi chứ tao quan trọng gì tao cũng có
gấu em nói đấy xong nó khác liền bạn có
tên mình đi Bạn nói bạn thích một đứa
nhưng mà có một đứa kho thích bạn hai
đứa đến với nhau con kia ngồi khóc lóc
liền à Anh ơi không đứa con gái em thích
nó cao hơn em một phân giờ phải làm sao
ngày nào cũng đi kéo sà Vậy á không việc
đi Cái loại mà loại giày bán ở ở cái
đường gì Cái gì giày vừa xấu của giá cao
ở Sài Gòn nên mình không biết được ăn
được gì đấy
Ờ bạn đi thật ra trông nó chỉ dán này
thôi nhưng bên trong có độ nên cứ này nè
con trai đi giày độn Không sao đâu em
Cái đấy là chuyện rất bình thường trước
đây người ta hay cười nhưng bây giờ có
gì đâu cũng nhu cầu thẩm mỹ Mà ai chả
muốn mình đẹp con gái được nâng ngực
nâng mũi cắt mong rồi bóp má là kiểu độn
mông có gì đâu mình đàn ông mình cũng
thích cao mình đi mình chọn chân mình
nên nói chuyện bình thường không có nên
yêu xa không phiêu nên tiêu xa vừa thể
hiện ở với con nhà người ta là mình có
tình yêu chân thành vừa không bị kiểm
soát tối đi đâu không nào biết anh bận
Tối nay anh rất toàn công ty dạo này
nhiều việc bạn bè anh nó rủ đi chơi đấy
thế ông rất khác nó được một công đôi
việc nên yêu xa cho cậu một
rồi thêm tiếp tục quên bao lâu mới được
hơn là cái gì làm quen bao lâu được hôn
lắm quen cái hôn luôn xong làm quen bao
lâu quen đó là con yêu quái là quay là
con chơi bạn bè thì không ôn cái quan
điểm rõ ràng như vậy và nó quen thoát nó
gật đầu cái rụp máy không Xi đây em có
yêu anh không Em có đồng ý làm chấp nhận
em cũng yêu anh nói tôi cúi xuống mà
quay đi thì mất giập vay lại hai tay ấn
cảnh báo người từ từ để nhập cho cả luôn
cái lúc đấy Lúc mà tình cảm đã cao trào
nó không kìm chết à
[âm nhạc]
a
nice
trùng hợp với
[âm nhạc]
một là
em đang bận lắm
ca nhạc ơi em đang
con bà
[âm nhạc]
như thế tất cả cái lý do đấy à
em
bảo có đi
[âm nhạc]
Ờ tôi không nghĩ là cái đi đây Đi đâu
ghé nhà được thôi tôi nhớ là cái video
bình thường khác rồi nó lớn đơn giản hơn
em nhớ Nhầm lý do rồi nhưng đại khái nói
như thế à
anh nói chung nhà với quan điểm bạn thân
khác giới thì tự với review thì không có
bạn thân khác giới tôi thì con điểm bản
thân ra rồi nó là có bốn người có thể
làm bạn hãy rồi được rồi từng nói rồi
Một là cả hai đều đang có người yêu rất
yêu người kia hay là
được đường dài rất là xấu bởi vì thằng
con trai xấu đứa con gái vẫn thích được
con đường ai xấu rồi thằng con trai tôi
không thích đâu Ba là cả hai người cùng
có vấn đề về giới tính theo kiểu không
có tâm trạng nhiều người ta rồi kia anh
cờ thế bốn là đường dài giờ điên Ê thằng
con trai rất điên đâu khi được nhà yêu
được như là Nhưng mà đừng ngày giờ điên
nó chai khó mà yêu được khó tán cô này
tôi từng thử không thể làm được bốn
trường hợp duy nhất tôi cảm thấy nó có
thể là có tình bạn khác giới Còn với
những trường hợp khác đấy thì
có
tình cảm với cơ thể xuất phát từ một
trong hai phía nên là tôi cảm thấy vẫn
không phải tình bạn thuần khiết lắm Bởi
vì vẫn có thể vẫn có thể cho phát mà có
thể ở mình coi người đấy là bạn thân
thật nhưng mà người đấy chưa chắc là con
mình của bạn thân
à Còn nếu mày không muốn thở thì tôi
từng thấy khá nhiều cái vụ thử Tôi nói
rồi đó tôi từng khá khó chịu là nhiều cũ
tôi khá thân một thằng thằng đấy còn thể
hiện luôn là nó thích thì yêu tôi và
tính nhờ
bạn đấy vẫn bảo em chỉ coi anh đấy là
bạn thân thôi mà Đấy và cho Và còn bảo
là anh ấy coi em mà bạn thân nó thử nó
bảo chỉ cần thử đơn giản thôi Nhắn tin
tỏ tình với đứa kia kiểu tao chết anh
đâu Hay là tao sẵn ta chán yêu người
khác rồi cho thấy mình hợp nhau thì yêu
không Nếu mà thực sự là Thằng ấy mà nhắn
tin lại cả thôi Tao nghĩ là chứng minh
chỉ nên làm bạn thì OK đúng còn mỗi khi
nó đồng ý thì sẽ sẵn các bạn biết rồi
đúng không ạ Thì đấy là nó sẵn sàng kiểu
anh chỉ đợi mình như thế chỉ là vì Bảo
Vinh nó ra thì ốm chỉ đợi mình chia tay
người yêu đều như hả mẹ nó thảm như thế
nên là không
Tôi không tin hoàn toàn vào cái tình bạn
khác giới kể cả đặc biệt là kể cả tri kỷ
của là là
thân nhau từ bé thực cá thân nhau từ bé
thì vẫn thể yêu nhau mà
chú ý tôi là phải cái việc là tình bạn
thân thiết là không thể yêu nhau ý thì
chị sẽ có 4 trường hợp thế thôi
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ nó bạn thân của em và em ăn cơm chó
của nó hoài tớ thì bởi vì nó đang yêu
người khác nhưng mà ông có chắc là ông
không có tình cảm với nó không
ạ Bây giờ nói chia tay xong rồi có ở nó
đến cạnh ông nó khóc lóc cho ông ngoại
cảm thấy à Rồi
nó cần một bờ vai chắc chắn
Tí sao không chắc chắn được điều gì tầm
này đặc biệt với ông chia tay xong mấy
ông còn rủ nhau đi uống bia có tí hơi
men nữa tôi khẳng định tôi quen rất
nhiều cái vụ như thế rồi
đi với main xong rồi làm lại làm gì đó
à à Thôi bữa hôm nay chắc à tâm sự cũng
tạm hiểu rồi chẳng ông nào thắc mắc thêm
gì cả nhưng mà ý tôi thì tôi không hẳn ở
hướng về sau ở cái kênh của tôi ngồi tâm
sự chuyện đó cả ngay nhưng mà tôi hướng
tới tôi làm phim Ơ đây là tôi sẽ có thể
vừa nói vừa cốt vừa nói về nhiều cái mà
và có thể Tôi không chắc chắn ơi tôi
đúng nhưng mà kiểu cũng nói anh em cùng
trao đổi Đấy thêm nhiều góc nhìn không ạ
em nói Sao bữa mày thì thôi Xin chào các
bạn nha À còn vụ chấm thì các bạn cứ
đăng ít rồi mình sẽ mình sẽ sửa xong cái
máy mình sẽ chậm sau vậy nhé chả bạn ạ